[Music]
oh baby
that is a hit song Gonna Love Me from
the singer dance and Dancer good Lord
can she dance and actor Tiana Taylor now
she's receiving Oscar buzz for her star
making performance and star making is a
is a word here in the new film it's
called a thousand one Taylor plays Inez
she's a New York City mother who kidnaps
her son from Foster Care to build a
better life together Amy winning writer
producer and actor that would be the one
and only Lena wife of the shy and Queen
in slim is a producer of this film a
thousand one was awarded the grand jury
prize at the Sundance Festival and
listen to this it's got a perfect score
on Rotten Tomatoes that's hard to do
here's a look look he's gonna be
go to war for you you know
you're not against anybody against this
whole city they can try all they want
they can try all they want but they're
not breaking us up this time
you want to find a new home
yes but I need to know we're in this
thing together so tell me
we're in this together tell me what is
together
and they are in it together too Tiana
Taylor and Lena Waits Jonas in the
studio bravo bravo bravo yes I don't
even know where to begin I'll just say
it has a really good plot twist at the
end that you have to get to the end to
see and it left me so wobbly watching
this movie I was wondering how can a
film be painful and uplifting at the
same time Lena I mean first I think that
sometimes what art can be you know I
think sometimes art can remind you of
something that was sort of hurtful or
painful but it also can remind you that
that's a thing that makes you who you
are yes and that's why you stand so tall
and I think that's why AV Rockwell's
amazing feature first feature film she
wrote and directed she put so much of
her pain but so much of the beauty of
New York City into the film and what
Tiana's doing is she's breathing life
into this woman Inez who I think is
representative of so many women yeah and
it's such a New York Film oh a throwback
to New York it's like a character right
out the gate let's talk about
because Tiana is it okay to mention on
TV you're getting Oscar buzz like big
Oscar buzz we want you to say that yeah
they're saying this is a start making
role but this is the thing about you I
read that you auditioned is this true 33
times to this part
did you no somebody I was like
saying that but I know it's like a
little inside joke
um I said a lot of times I had to read
for it a lot it was really more so a lot
of work shopping we did a lot of work
shopping and we did a lot of layering to
Inez why did you want it so but you
auditioned many many times maybe not 33
but it was it was one it was one
audition
it was one self-tape audition strong
audition and then AV just wanted to keep
getting on the phone I think she she
loved me from that day I don't think she
would have kept making me get on the
phone right you know I think at that
point after the first audition it was
mine to lose I want to say you know but
I was willing to do the work and that's
all that matters so it didn't matter how
many times I didn't find whether it was
eight or thirty three times yeah I would
have done it yeah I've heard you said
that you wanted to be taken seriously in
this craft yes I did tell us about that
um I have been in a lot of projects but
it was always like dancing or like being
a sexy girl and I just wanted to be
stripped down I wanted to be in a
dramatic role that would really give me
that shot I had lost a lot of
opportunities with people just thinking
like well do she have the chops like you
know people like you know either AV like
my name was mentioned you know Tiana's
from harlems you'd be perfect I was like
yeah but yeah I haven't really seen her
do anything you know so just I got tired
of that I didn't want anybody feeling
like they had to like second guess if I
had what it took so yeah perfect
opportunity it was a little tough for me
because you know Tiana and I have a real
friendship and I think because I was you
know as a producer on the film I didn't
want AV to think that I was you know
pushing trying to you know like uh well
look I think uh Tiana's it
and but then just as a producer I was
able to separate myself from the
friendship and say no she's it and AV
was like you're right yes and this is
this is the person and I think you all
see why uh the the right decision was
made yeah I can't imagine anyone else in
this role uh you completely embody the
character and it's a hard character to
play right she's got all the love in the
world for this child Terry but she
doesn't always make what people in the
audience are going to think are the best
decisions or express yourself in exactly
the way they would at home
as a mother of two yourself I'm sure you
also see that I mean how did you get
into this character and strike that
balance between all that love and all
those flaws as well
Inez was a very very heavy character
um as a mom one I was I had just had a
newborn so I was dealing with a lot of
like postpartum depression and then
taking on a role having to go back home
which was amazing going back home is
amazing but I went back home and seen
like a different city it wasn't really
the city that I knew I felt like a lot
of the history in the season and so have
been erased or reduced
um on top of like my childhood being
erased I lost a lot of friends uh to
death during that time so I was like
literally going to funerals during my
lunch break so it was almost like
therapeutic to pour into Inez because I
got to cry out loud for once I got to
just be weak for once I got to just put
my Cape to the side put my strong woman
came to the side because you know I us
black women we're strong for everyone we
show up for everyone but when it's time
to show up for ourselves and and have
strengths within ourselves as an issue
right you know so with a lot of those
quiet battles that I was fighting um I
was able to kind of just put all that to
the side and just pour into Inez so it
was kind of easy to really tap into this
very heavy character because I knew that
once AV yell cut yeah okay put the cake
back on super mom Super Wife wow super
artist what are you going to wear to the
Oscars I'd like to thank the academy
Erica Badu was on Ari Melbourne's beat
yesterday and they asked about you she
said she's fresh she's live She's My
Babe yeah that's Erykah Badu who never
gives interviews I thought that was
great and let me say this before we go
um no Gail gave you guys an intro you
are two of the most talented in the
business so versatile and we are huge
fans in this project it's incredible
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much cheering you on always
a thousand and one premieres in theaters
this Friday
this morning